ああああああ
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
うん中原です
私は高校野球に携わって監督生活が32年を過ぎました
場所学園で22年間
そして長野地のや高校で充電カンテイ
32年です
現在は
今年の4月から
日本ウエルネス信州ちこコーデ
村野大変なの支援を受けて
その新しい新設校で野球部の監督をさせていただいています
多くの生徒から学んだこと
多くの試合から経験したこと
そして
全国のトップクラスの監督チームの5町3
その多くの学んだことを教
この皆様の前でお話をさせて頂きたいというように思います
永山県の高校野球盤
全国の
中で活躍することそして全国大会で
立てるために良い
皆さんご存知だと思いますけれども
全国大会高校野球の全国大会というのは春夏の甲子園大会
そして秋の明治神宮大会
そして何走大会の優秀能チームの国体ということです
芭蕉学園長野日大高校
800人以上の教え子は
できました
その中から生徒に教わったこと
そして学んだことをその生徒と接して
高校野球の中で
こうしたら良くなるんだろうな
成功するんだろうなぁということをまず号項目話をさせていただきます
一つ
挨拶がしっかりできる人
これは
本音の地震
積極性を表す形です
2番目
食事がしっかりできる人
健康管理体力そして技術の向上の源です
3番目に服装がしっかりしていること
これは学生としてまた選手としての
9ミリ区別がきちんとする力を持ってる人
4番目に反復練習がしっかりできる人
粘り強い
そして努力工夫研究に結びついていく力です
5番目に一つの武器特長を持ってる人です自分の良いところを伸ばす力がありそして人
から
人の良さを
くみ取る目を持ってるという大事な力です
この5つの問題ねー
一番根底して二つ共通することがありますその一つは
聞く力を持っている人です
中国の言葉に二巡という言葉があります
家空姿勢
例で言えば身を正して切っ
妙を乗り出して聞く
目を輝蒸して聞く
こういう力です
そしてもう一つ
誰よりも
貴族力の能力の高い人
傷口から月が良ければ当然ながら行動も変わる
報道を変われば結果が変わってくる
高校野球は所詮
2年と半年
他の競技も同じでしょうけれども
1巡は早く学年を問わず
気づいた人が最終的には立ちます
相手のチームに戦う前に自分のチームの中に
戦いがありますそれはこの2つです
いかに気持ちの自信をつけさせるか
心の強さはどうやって植え付けるかっ
もう一つは力の自信です体力技術戦力
先日そういう二戦ですこの2つがしっかりできること
相まった時に素晴らしい結果な生まれます
そして一番大事なことは常日頃に
監督と選手の信頼確保を作ることそして自分の持っている情報をきちんと生徒に伝える
こと
そして+あ
大事なことを常に
れ10試合で
者から釣りではありませんけど餌をまいてその x 用車
22臭くておくことです
10大会の上位を呼び全国大会で戦うために
今長野県の高校野球の主導者が一番心がけることは私は情報収集と
分析能力だというように思っています
学校
全国の中で
泥くらい自分の
ネットワークをつくるか各中学校
シニアリーグ boys リーム少年役いろんなことがあります
高校大学マスコミ関係
あらゆるネットワークを広げる努力をすることです
大きな大会での抽選の
しゃべて密会第2自分の手元にすべての対戦相手の情報が集まることが望ましいことだ
と思ってます
ここからはわかりやすく実例を挙げて説明します
私と選手とでの甲子園の成績
甲子園での謎大会8回
春の大会3回計11回必要させていただきました
その中で
総試合数25試合
戦績は14勝11敗
準優勝1回
べそエイド2階
ベスト16願いです
勝利の内訳
2点歳以上での勝利が14勝のうち8勝
57.1%です
配線の内訳以前差以内の敗戦が11敗のうちの6回
54.5%です
春夏の総得点が117点
春夏大会での総失点が107点です
なんと25試合で得失点の差がじっ点しかありません
ここで過去10年間の夏の甲子園の県代表の成績は3勝7敗です
今年の
本県代表の佐久長聖高校も残念ながら3対3という形の堰合でした
3勝7敗7敗のうちの再試合が
に天才の配線のゲームです
この数字から見て
この中で3
7回のうちの3ゲームさえ取れば
5勝5敗の豪雨に持ってくるわけです
先ほど言いました
選手と私の成績と見比べても
共通する点があると思います
一つは第1ゲームも
第一ないっ2点差ゲームをどのようにとるか
もっと月進めれば1点を取るか言ってを捉えるからの戦いになります
私は決して県内の広報野球は悲壮感と悲観をして戦わなくては良いと思います
この現実をきちんと
認めて
日々の練習試合臨むことが大事だと思っています
ここで一礼を申し上げます
私は
3拭いと思いますがこういうひとつの相手戦力分析用途の各チームで作っています
この中では52もに項目の戦力分析の一つのポイントが乗ってます
この中で
情報戦略分析の女奴とするのは
70%の数字が超えた時です
その数字が上回った時には試合の中で
完全に私は決断をして実行します
わかりやすくみなさんといいますと
野球で言うさんはで打者というのは
実家行って30本の人です
これは1ユーザー者と言われます
100回打ってん25本のヒットはニュアリフォーム等が車
普通の打者と言われます
似たような数字だと思っております
2重率が上がれば上がるほど自信を持って試合の中で実行します
私は高校野球という
または野球というスポーツはスポーツの中で
非常に難しいスポーツだと思っております
一つは簡単に言いますとスポーツのルールブックの本で野球の方が一番厚いということ
そして
普通の試合で
両チームが投げる投手の双方の投球数を合わせると約240級からね160球になり
ます
その数字の中で
ストライクボールで有利不利が現れるスポーツです
そこの心理的な重圧は大変なものです
高校野球の宿命としてトーナメントの戦いです
その大会で一つその試合を負ければ次に進めない
非常に重圧のかかる
特に3年生の最後の試合というのには心理的な重圧は計り知れないものがあります
これが
あと2年で
高校役が100年の全国大会を迎えます
そして一つの日本の文化として認められている
今の現状の主が誰ではないかというように思っています
縫製または大きな第2位で近い試合を発揮するには
反応の夏の甲子園 nhk の集計時よりますけれども
普通のゲームで全国で2000万人の人がゲームを観戦しています
そしてビッグゲームになれば4000万人以上の人が
び亭ということです
先ほど申しましたよねー
入ってんのゲームをどうやって撮る
その一つの現実の情報を常日頃から練習の中試合の中で選手に
情報をしっかり理解されてを事これが一番大事ではないかと思いますし強いチームに
立ち向かっていく心を養っていくことが大変重要ではないかと
いうように思ってますそして
もう一つは相手校の特徴の良さをしっかり認めることそしてそれを利用すること
欠点弱点は徹底して言葉が悪いですけれども嫌らしく
調べて攻め抜くことチーム一丸で
チーム全員ての1回戦一貫性がヒロン台です
入学時から3つ目
個人チームを型にはめないこと
本人の特性を徹底して伸ばすことが大事です
4番目にはスペシャリーズと育成すること
御祈祷師
強い左投資に強い守備がうまい
判断力は良い脚が速い方が強い
声が大きい野球を知っているこういう特性を伸ばしてやることですこれはチームに勢い
がつくる大きな力なり相手のチームが予想以上に9
を使ってくれる状況を作り出します
次に日々指導者が心
なった訳て心がけていかなければいけない状況
そして
全国のトップクラスの多くの監督に共通点があると思います
11に情熱があること
女
使命感を持ってやっていること3行動力を持っていること
4勉強をしていること
東方をしっかり生徒に伝えることそしてこれも今天に2つの大事なことがあります
一つは生徒の将来を常に考えていること
2番目ねー
指導者は陥りやすいや誤りですがあまりにも教えすぎないこと
ヒントを与えて導いてやることが大事だと思いますそして
野球の自分のチームの関係者に絶対に作っていけないのは申し訳ないですが
弁護士と評論家は絶対つくらないそういう妥協を求めるようなことはさしてはならない
というように思ってます
全国の多くの監督指導者と知り接して知り合って感じたこと
トップクラスの監督そ
日々の監督の努力の差がチームの実力の差となる
日々の監督の責任感の差がチームの実績となう
日々の監督のプロのさおよび勉強が人格の里 now
日々の監督の情報量の多さがゲームでの
別段力の差となるこんなように感じています
そして生徒に一番教えたいことは何度の心
高校野球のバンドは
非常に大事です
このバンドとは人を送り人を進めて人を迎えるという意味を持っています
人を送り1オススメというバンドは送りバンド
セーフティーバンドブッシュバンド
人を迎えるというスバンドはスクイズバンド
セーフティースクイズということがあります
バンドの中に後方野球の心が私はあると思っています
人間として
社会人になっていく生活の中で
すべてにおいて共通する
通ずることだと思っています
チームの勝利の為
会社では会社の成果を挙げるため自分の疫病を果たして
そして同僚半ばについを絶つ
一つの生活の中では非常に大事な
ことではないかというふうに思っています
ここで皆さん
野球の中でホームベースという一番大事だ
ベースがありますホームペースの
夢を知ってる人はいますかねぇどうですかねぇ
ちょっと逆光とあるですがあまりないようですけどもこのホームベースっていうのは
まあアメリカでこういうひとつ本ベストいう名前がついているわけですけれども
普通の生活の過程と同じなんですね
お父さんお母さんが働きに出る
世の中ていろんなプロをして1日顔や手
家に帰ってくる野球で言えば
一塁ベースを回り二塁ベースを回り三塁ベース
いろんな試練ながあるところをくぐり抜けてきてホームに辿ってついた無事着いた
自分の我が家と一緒ですという形の中でご褒美に1点という形で名前がついたんです
そういうひとつの大事さを送りバンドという一つの
リースで選手が知っていただければもっと多くの振り深いことになると思います
野球度が好きで小学校4年生当時から初めてこの歳まで行ってきました
多くの生徒に大変恵まれて幸せものでした
1 pt も早く県代表が全国大会で通用しそして活躍し
多くの県外のチームがこの長野県の高校野球のチームを目指して練習人会いに来て
くれると
ことを望んでいますそして1日も早く全国で
県代表が勝つ8つくるそして偏ることを望んでいます
本当に今日はありがとうございました
[拍手]